leaders of a deeply divided group of
seven leading industrial countries are
meeting in the French resort city of
Yuans president Donald Trump is out of
step with the rest efforts to reach
consensus look set to founder over
thorny issues including global trade
climate change and taxing the big
technology companies divisions are so
deep that for the first time in more
than 40 years there's to be no joint
communique at the end of the g7 summit
and I'm joined now by DW as Georg mattis
in Biarritz York it's the first time
since 1975 that there's going to be no
communicate at this summit why is that
I'd say really this is a precautionary
measure that the French president has
taken a president here who's hosting the
g7 and who is in damage control mode
ever since President Donald Trump the US
president walked away from that final
declaration at the last meeting in
Canada and so what the French president
has done he has really broadened the
agenda he has brought in all sorts of
other topics like the environment like
development unlike injustice in the
world in order to if you want paper over
the rifts that are so clearly there when
it comes to topics like the environment
the French the the Paris climate Accord
or for instance the Iran nuclear deal
something that is very important to
European partners here in the g7 but
something that he walked away from so
they're gonna be doing a lot of talking
but without a final communique or
agreement for action is there any point
meeting well the g7 has been around for
for for more than four decades basically
and it is the forum to organize
international trade it is the forum to
organize international relations if you
want this is where the rules how this
system that we're all living in is has
been hammered out this is how a problems
can mutually be solved and the French
president is very keen to produce some
sort of tangible results and end in his
first meeting with President Donald
Trump he had some hope for optimism
because after all Donald Trump said the
weather is great there's very friendly
people around and there's great things
that can be accomplished and while
we'll have to see if that is true in the
run-up to this meeting the II used trade
pact with South America's Mercosur group
has been threatened if brazil's
government doesn't take action let's
have a listen to what au Council
President Donald Tusk had to say earlier
the burning Amazon rainforest has become
another depressing sign of our times
we of course stand by the EU America su
agreement which is also about protecting
the climate and environment but it is
hard to imagine how Moniz process of
ratification by the European countries
as long as the Brazilian government
allows for the destruction of the green
length of planet Earth Europe do you see
the EU actually taking this kind of
action against Brazil it's a crucial
role it's very high on their agenda and
so that is why also the German Foreign
Minister has emphasized that it is a
real problem also looking towards that
that trade deal
Donald Rose was also clear in May in
saying that this trade deal with the
Mercosur estates also will help the
environment but at the same time backing
the French president so yes I would say
you know the Europeans have worked with
the Americas to estates for more than
two decades on that deal if that paper
lies a little longer on the table until
these key problems are sorted out that
is something that Europeans would be
prepared to do ok DW your grant is in
Biarritz thanks for that